veterans to discuss ways that we and the
industry could attract train place and
retain veterans in trucking jobs and
today we're pleased to announce the
departments of labor transportation
defense veterans affairs and the small
business administration will be raising
awareness about 16 different federal
programs that can uh that can connect
transitioning military personnel and
veterans to rewarding careers in the
trucking industry a highlight of these
efforts is the department of labor's
registered apprenticeship program so we
see this as a win-win-win getting more
veterans to work addressing the
shortages in the tracking industry also
wanted to note that
as you've heard the president talk about
a fair amount he's committed to using
every tool at his disposal to bring down
prices and you're going to hear him talk
and the administration talk a lot about
this as the as the week proceeds that's
why we're working to east supply chain
bottlenecks and give consumers more
choices that's why we continue to push
for legislation like bill beck better
and a competitiveness bill that will
make our economy stronger lower the cost
of essentials bring more manufacturing
to the united states and strengthen our
supply chains this week the president is
also going to be meeting with business
leaders and traveling in the country to
virginia as you know to highlight his
plan to address prices uh while we're
mate we've made remarkable strides with
the fastest economic growth since 1984
and the most jobs created in one year
ever he knows there's more work to do
to keep prices down uh he will he also
talked this afternoon as you just all
heard him do about how we can build more
in america and bring down costs through
making more in america and rebuilding
our supply chains and as i noted
tomorrow he'll be hosting ceos at the
white house to talk about how billback
better can lower energy costs as you
know he's going to virginia on thursday
to talk about lowering uh the price of
prescription drugs with that colleen why
don't you kick us off okay a couple
things um do you have any information
about a possible security threat at
dunbar high school where the second
gentleman was i think he was just taken
from
the event and it was postponed but we
don't know
i don't have any updates on this we will
venture to see if we can get you
anything even if it's during the
briefing it just happens yeah okay
excellent um and then second uh
the
remaining child tax credit is um
you know the
fight administration is encouraging
people to use what's up to their
remaining tax credit so to what extent
um do you hope that
you can show the benefits of the program
to overcome skepticism about the program
kind of by getting this last bunch of
money out there one more thing
sure well uh one of the steps we're
trying to take here which is which is
showcased by the fact that today the
vice president secretary yellen and gene
sperling are hosting a day of action
with over 100 non-profits and
community-based organizations
to encourage all americans to take
advantage of critical tax credits
including the expanded child tax credit
and earn income tax credit when they
file their taxes this year
part of the reason we're doing that is
because we know how effective it is we
know that it helped cut child poverty by
40
last year we know it helped give many
families some extra breathing room at a
time where the economy was still
recovering and studies show that the
child tax credit also helps working
families with development with
developments and opportunities for their
children uh it's important to remember
there's one of the things they'll be
talking about today that americans that
qualified for the extended child tax
credit will still receive half of the
entire benefit when they file their
taxes this year and yesterday we
launched a new version of child tax
credit.gov to help americans get the
full child tax credit as tax filing
season begins so part of our effort here
is to continue to talking about continue
talking about the benefits how they're
helping working families uh how they're
helping uh
uh many women who need uh who need extra
hand to cover child care costs uh and
how they're helping uh give people a
little extra breathing room um and then
lastly
if dr lander the president um
accepted his resignation
last night i think
last night
um i mean
it's not gonna go back to yesterday's
discussion but should he just fire him
to begin with if he was just going to
offer his resignation anyway and
spare all of this criticism from
yesterday i mean
should there have been things done
differently i guess well let me
reiterate something i said uh yesterday
because i think it's important for
people to hear that from the outset dr
lander's behavior was unacceptable
senior white house officials conveyed
that to him directly at the conclusion
of the investigation and of course we
talked about that yesterday and what
happened here is we took we as a part of
the implementation of the safe and
respectful workplace policy something
that we
implemented and announced last may or
put out there last may
we implemented a process including an
investigation including a meeting that
dr lander had with senior white house
officials to convey uh the severity of
his actions and what steps he was
expected to take and the fact that there
would be a complaint he would be
expected to be compliant as you saw we
released dr lander's note last night to
all of you or his letter of resignation
i should say uh it was made clear to him
uh through the course of the day
yesterday i suppose that he could no
longer lead ostp effectively
and he conveyed that in his letter the
president accepted his resignation
so i think we're now focused on looking
forward there's obviously a lot of
important work that ostp will do
continue to do and continue to lead on
moving forward and the president's eager
to continue working with them go ahead a
couple on ukraine um president macron
says that he believes that he achieved
this objective of preventing an
escalation after his date with vladimir
putin
what if the french shared with the white
house about that meeting and does the
white house believe that we are today
closer to seeing de-escalation as a
result of this meeting than we were
yesterday
well uh the meeting and the press
conference as you may have seen ended
very late uh last night so obviously we
are we'll continue to be in very close
contact with our french counterparts at
a range of levels the president has
spoken with uh with president macron
twice in the last week i expect he'll be
engaged with him soon which we will of
course uh to go back to kelly's question
yesterday make you all aware of um i i
would just say we encouraged and we're
encouraged by any efforts at diplomacy
uh we can't uh
we still don't have any prediction of
what president putin will do we can't
control what russia will do next uh what
we can do and what i think president
macron played a role in doing yesterday
is making clear with our allies and
partners that there will be massive
consequences should putin choose to
further invade ukraine but in terms of
an assessment we don't have any new
information or new prediction about
where president
touch with our counterparts but i don't
have an update on on any specifics of
behind-the-scenes diplomatic talks
ukraine we heard the president and the
chancellor yesterday emphasized this
united front we did not hear the
chancellor
mention the phrase nordstrom 2 what
assurances did this white house get from
germany to the german government about
nordstrom 2 the future of that pipeline
with russian days well as you heard the
president very definitively say
yesterday at the press conference if
russia further invades ukraine there
will no longer be nordstrom 2 and we
will bring an end to it you heard the
german chancellor also convey yesterday
that we are working in lockstep and that
we are very coordinated in our efforts
in terms of the specifics we'll let
those conversations happen through
diplomatic channels but i would also
reiterate that nordstrom 2 is not
currently operational we agree that it
is a point of leverage with president
putin and the russians german regulators
have suspended certification of the
pipeline and we have been very clear
privately as we have been publicly about
uh the fact that it would not continue
should russia invade one last one uh
your reaction to the rnc declaring what
happened on january 6 as a legitimate
political discourse and democrats on the
hill today are being very vocal about
this king jeffrey says the c and r and c
c stands for cult does the white house
agree with that well i think it's clear
to americans that what happened on
january 6th was not legitimate political
discourse storming the capital in an
attempt to halt the peaceful transition
of power is not legitimate political
discourse neither is attacking and
injuring over 140 police officers
smashing windows and defiling offices
it's telling to all of us that some
leading republicans have rejected that
characterization including the former
president's national security advisor
and the chief of staff to the former
vice president who as he put it had a
front row seat that day including his
riders chanted for the former vice
president to be hanged uh so again we
certainly reject the notion that that
was legitimate political discourse as we
think a very uh a large number of
americans would as well
go ahead thanks jen i want to ask you
about this army after action
investigation into the afghanistan
withdrawal that was obtained by the
washington post first of all is this a
report that the white house has had an
opportunity to review and absorb and if
so were there any lessons that were
learned from it
well uh i know obviously our national
security team as we said at the time uh
was going to conduct after action
reports as they would as it relates to
the end of any conflict or any
engagement of that sort um you know we
have always believed that the end of a
20-year war was always going to have
significant challenges um we uh as you
know and we talked about at the time
through the summer we were pressing our
system hard on whether we were meeting
previously established tripwires that
would require us to adjust operations at
embassy kabul that's how we looked at it
and evaluated at the time the nsc led
that process and convened regular
interagency discussions and of course
earlier in the summer we pre-positioned
u.s forces in the region to be ready to
facilitate a neo in preparation of
exactly that scenario i know i reiterate
all of that because i know we haven't
talked about this in great detail in
some time so i just wanted to lay it all
out there uh all that work of course
took months of planning but we always
look at and assess uh af that's why
after action reports are so important
and so essential in terms of additional
reports out of any of these findings i
don't have anything to report from here
i'd really point you to the department
of defense has the white house had an
opportunity to review this particular
report
well again
internal uh internal discussions and
internal uh reviews of uh any uh of any
after-action reports i i don't have any
updates on our assessments from here
among the criticisms from military
commanders in the document is that as
late as early august of last year the
nsc
appeared to lack a sense of urgency
about planning for an evacuation because
it would signal that we have failed
what's your reaction to that criticism
well i would say again
earlier in the summer we pre-positioned
u.s forces to be ready to facilitate a
neo if needed meaning an evacuation if
needed of of uh our embassy there that
is fact in terms of what was planning
what was done at the time and that in
advance of that that required months of
planning to ensure there were a range of
contingencies planned for as we always
do through the national security team
and through the military team and as we
prepared in the early summer
to leave afghanistan we pre-positioned
military assets in the region that
enabled us to execute one of the largest
airlifts in history so i would just say
if you look back at the specific
planning steps we took uh we did plan
for a range of contingencies even well
as we talked about at the time there
wasn't an anticipation that uh that um
that the afghan national security forces
would fall as they did or as quickly as
they did and that was not anticipated by
anyone but we still had done a range of
contingency planning so broadly then do
you reject the assertion that was made
by various military commanders in this
report that they were trying to convince
members of the administration of the
urgency of planning for the evacuation
but that they were rebuffed
well again there was a range of
contingency planning that was done in
close coordination by all the players on
the national security team at the time
to prepare for a range of options and a
range of outcomes no one predicted as we
know and as we talked about a lot during
the period of august and september that
the afghan national security forces
would fall at the pace they fell but if
you look back at the history of what we
actually did and what planning was done
there was a range of planning including
positioning military forces including
ensuring that we had a plan for a neo
operation for evacuation at the time
should that be needed uh so we we always
look back and assess but i would say the
facts of what was planned for at the
time uh show that we were preparing for
a range of contingencies
good following up real quick on this
last um exchange
that report did paint a pretty damning
picture of
the nfc and state department pretty much
having blinders on while
generals sounded the alarm over
afghanistan but we're hearing sort of
the same bleak blunt assessments right
now from the pentagon about ukraine so
is there
i guess any is there any closer
relationship between uh the white house
and pentagon are the military are the
generals being listened to
differently now post afghanistan post
this report well i think it's really
important to to to separate the two
because first you we're not in a 20-year
wrote war with u.s troops in ukraine
that's a very different circumstance
i would say that we believe and we
continue to view our relationship both
from the white house from the diplomatic
team and from this uh from the defense
department as one where we are closely
coordinating where there are there are
healthy disagreements as there can be
and the president certainly welcomes
them and after action reports are very
important uh because you can look at and
make assessments about anything you
would change moving forward but uh
ukraine and and the circumstance the
situation on the border of ukraine with
russian troops building up is not the
same as ending a 20-year war uh that is
something the president had talked about
for some time uh where we were spending
an enormous amount of not just uh money
but blood of american service members
further over the course of decades
that's a different circumstance and then
on this meeting between putin and macron
yesterday it sounds like the white house
does not have a clear idea yet about
whether there was in fact a deal or not
for russia to
de-escalate uh or i'd rather not to go
give any further escalation um obviously
the kremlin
denied reports that the french put out
about having struck a deal
uh if the us is not aware of where
things stand doesn't that signal that
there's a separate negotiating track
happening between the europeans and
russia right now that could
put the u.s at risk of being sort of
shut out from that discussion
not in any way i completely disagree
with what you just conveyed uh first of
all there are a range of diplomatic
conversations happening all the time and
that's been
the case for many weeks the united
states is a key player in the vast
majority of those negotiations at the
same time there are important formats
whether it is bilateral leader to leader
engagement which president macron was a
part of yesterday or
the normandy format which is something
we fully support which is the format
that the minsk agreement would be
discussed through which includes ukraine
russia uh georgia uh and france uh
that's another format that we fully
supported those are conversations that
have been happening and typically
through a diplomatic process there are a
range of conversations that are
happening at the same time again as i
noted a little bit earlier the president
spoke with president macron twice over
the last week including on sunday the
day before he spoke with president putin
and i expect he'll speak with him soon
again but it's also important to note
that there are others german are the
german chancellor who was just here
yesterday is also meeting with uh
president putin tomorrow and certainly
if there is diplomatic progress we would
welcome that but we will believe it when
we see it with our own eyes at the
border on the warships that moved in uh
to the black sea
uh there are some people who are fearing
that this is another invasion force
potentially targeting the city of odessa
obviously the criminal saying this is
just uh exercises but is there concern
in the white house that you know while
we're buying time this diplomatic push
that putin is just
bolstering uh his his forces building
his forces while we're all
talking sure well i know that um my
colleague john kirby has spoken to this
from the pentagon so i'd point you to
his comments um but i would say that we
are not we are always going to leave the
door to diplomacy open because we think
as long as we don't know what president
putin is going to do and we don't and he
has not invaded ukraine at this point
then it is important to always keep that
door open because that's always the
preferred path at the same time we are
not just talking we have built uh
through 200 engagements talking is
engaged in part is important part of it
i guess but
to build a um a an agreement with our
partners and allies in europe about
putting together a severe set of
economic consequences should they decide
to invade we have provided an enormous
amount of security assistance to ukraine
to make sure they are prepared so we are
working on a number of paths as you
should do but diplomacy is always going
to be the preferred path
yeah when are we going to hear from the
cdc
on this guidance california yesterday
changed their guidance randy weingarten
teachers union
is
focally asking for the white house and
the cdc to weigh in so when are we going
to hear from the cdc about
updating the guidance
you'll have to ask the cdc the cdc moves
at the pace of data and science i would
note that our goal remains continuing to
ensure that there is guidance that helps
school districts stay open that's our
goal we want kids to be in school 98 of
schools are open that's a very let me
finish that's a very good sign we know
it works the cdc is always going to be
reviewing their guidance including mass
guidance but inclu in terms of when they
will provide additional new guidance
that is up to them do you believe then
that the state the democratic-led states
who are
breaking with the cdc on this guidance
that they're not
that they're throwing science away and
that the cdc has access to different
science sometimes we don't look at it
through that prism
these states i think it's important to
note they still allow for decisions to
be made by local school districts where
we come up with concern where we have
great concern if it is if a kid or a
parent chooses to wear a mask or school
district decides they should keep mass
guidance in place and there are leaders
who are preventing them from doing that
that is the place in some other states
but our hope is that
states leaders will look at the science
and data about what's going on
they'll make decisions about local
school districts local school districts
have always made these decisions that
remains the case go ahead let's ask
about the supreme court process sure
three weeks left before the president
who's counting
has any
of this process move to a point where
you are requesting documents background
materials directly from
those women who are among the potential
choices
and also how are you facilitating the
president
in getting advice from allies and so
forth uh on the outside who may want to
pitch their favorite uh contenders uh
we're certainly seeing lawmakers and
others speaking publicly
that's a little different than speaking
directly to the president how is that
information getting to him
sure well let me start with the second
part and i'll come back to the first uh
to the best of my ability uh so you all
have seen that the president has met
with very publicly uh both chairman
dermond durbin and ranking member
grassley uh the chairman and the
president and vice president have also
spoken with a number of members to
engage with them get their feedback i
had also noted i think yesterday that
the president um has also spoken with a
wide range of of outside legal experts
as he's seeking
to consult and to get feedback and
advice from them so he is receiving and
engaging with a range of people as he
considers this process i would note also
that as he's looking at the process he's
reviewing not just bios but he's also
reviewing cases and he is looking at
binders of cases because he is very
taking this approach very seriously he's
taking a very thorough approach to it in
terms of the process that is that isn't
a part of the process as you know from
covering these kelly
vetting documents and that requires uh
um
engagement with individuals i'm not
going to get into specifics about where
that sits what i would reiterate uh from
the and those of you who have covered
this know this well is that we we
later in the process the very end of the
process is typically when the president
would interview candidates uh we remain
uh we are remain on track to announce a
nominee by the end of the month but that
is typically the very end of the process
can you say that the field is narrowed a
bit from the dozen or so that we were
originally talking about that is a
natural part of the process but i'm not
going to get into specifics of the
numbers
go ahead going back to the after action
report on the abbey gate investigation
it's incredible what is in this report
some of the military officials say
things such as the department of state
did not get one message right to the
afghans during the neo marines and abby
gate were forced to play god by
identifying who would be allowed into
the air field
one of the reasons you do an after
action report as you said is to go back
and assess but
isn't it also to allow for
accountability does the president intend
to seek any accountability
i think we're going to allow a
discussion internally uh to continue
about any after-action report i have no
predictions beyond that at this point
speaking of accountability last night
accepting the resignation of the dr
lander
it's been postulated here in town that
perhaps dr later would still be working
for this administration if politico
hadn't reported the story yesterday
morning and if reporters in this room
hadn't asked about it yesterday is that
a fair assessment
well i think again given that dr lander
made the decision himself to submit his
resignation that would be a question
best posed to him the president was not
involved no he was not he did not seek
dr landers he did not he made the
decision himself
good uh frontier has announced plans to
buy spirit airlines is there any concern
in this administration about reduced
competition
you know broadly speaking we always have
a concern about reduced competition but
in terms of this uh potential merger i
don't have any specific comment from
here is it under discussion at least
again you know that would be reviewed by
the department of justice and not from
here so i don't have any additional
comment from here uh china as has been
widely reported has has
largely missed its phase one purchase
commitments uh there's been talk about
administration
officials voicing this uh disappointment
over that frustration what is the
president prepared to do uh on that
front
well i would say first that um
hold on i have some
update on this let me just make sure i
haven't received information one moment
thanks for your patience
um
so uh as you know and have been
following this closely alex uh the ustr
has been in conversations with china
about its performance regarding purchase
commitments under phase one which they
did not meet in 2020 and did not meet in
2021 and uh they have conveyed and i
just reiterate on their behalf the ustr
officials it is on china to show can
follow through on its commitment um so
our again this is under the purview as
you know of ambassador thai
we have expressed our concerns we have
them in terms of specifically what the
president would be prepared to do we're
going to continue to engage with
ambassador thai and the trade team to
determine next steps just to be clear
what is the president prepared to do
then again the ustr our ambassador tai
is the one who runs point on this uh and
i would point to her for any additional
comment on the current status finally uh
there's some talk on on capitol hill
about congressional staffers unionizing
does the president support that
he does
uh he supports the right of any
individual to uh seek to join a union uh
to collective bargain uh and of course
uh capitol hill staffers are certainly
individuals who
are pursuing that is the staff in touch
with those folks our staff been in touch
with them i i would really point you to
congressional leadership i know speaker
pelosi and her team have spoken to this
as well go ahead thanks chef uh so
truckers at cad uh last night shut down
the ambassador bridge which carries
about a quarter of u.s canada trading
goods um so what's the administration's
response uh to this action and what
steps are being taken to ensure the free
flow of goods and also
any preventative steps being taken to
address a possible blockade on the
michigan side of that bridge well let me
first start by saying i know there's
been some suggestion not by reporters
necessarily at all but that
this congestion is related to the
vaccine requirements it's not uh i mean
i i'm saying i'm going to get to the
protests but the protests uh going on
across canada which have spread to a
bridge or leading to sporadic congestion
and blockages i would just to go back to
my point i was trying to make is that um
across what we've seen with these
requirements is across in just a range
of industries vaccine vaccination
requirements have been implemented with
no disruptions have helped increase
vaccinations these requirements help
protect more people from covid and
there's been zero indication across
these industries that they would lead to
disruptions including on this policy
we of course support as you know the the
right to freedom of speech and protest
um but we and while we do see some of
these congestion due to process this is
clear that these disruptions have
broadened in scope beyond the vaccine
requirement implementation uh we beyond
that we are of course in touch with our
canadian counterparts um but i don't
have any updates in terms of specific
steps on
ukraine so yesterday in yesterday's
briefing um you mentioned that the minsk
agreements would possibly be a part of
these macron and putin taughts and now
that it's over you know is the u.s
discussing directly with any of the
parties the use of the mints agreement
as a possible way out of the conflict as
as president zelonski has suggested do
you see that as a sort of a fruitful
pathway toward of diplomatic agreement
well we we see the minsk agreements
which which are discussed through the
normandy format which i was talking
about a little bit earlier um as um as a
as a as certainly a format to move
things forward and we stand ready to
support these sincere efforts and again
we we welcome calls for a diplomatic
resolution to the conflict in eastern
ukraine and the minsk agreement is a is
a format that those could take place
through well i guess there's been some
suggestions that the midst agreement
would be unfavorable
toward ukraine if
implemented in the way that the russians
want implemented so uh
does the us coming down in any way
we are not we just see them as a format
through which uh there could be
discussion and continued engagement
lastly quickly on competition uh you
know tyson food stock went up uh very
high yesterday i think its highest in
about two years uh on the back of record
profits on rising meat price partially
at prices rising prices so how's that
close good challenge to your
administration's efforts to address
competition in that industry
well um just four large conglomerates
control the majority of the market for
beef pork and poultry products and the
data shows up and i think their record
profits are evidence of this there have
been
increases in meat prices well companies
have generated recent record profits and
that's a good example of it and i would
just note just if you look at historical
precedent here 50 years ago ranchers got
over 60 cents for every dollar a family
spent on beef today they get about 39
cents 50 years ago hog farmers got 40 to
60 cents for each dollar they spent
today it's about 19 cents and the big
companies are still making major profits
it certainly shouldn't work that way and
as the president has said many times
capitalism without competition isn't
capitalism it's exploitation and we have
continued concern about the lack of
competition in these industries go ahead
thank you general i have a lander and a
ukraine question first of all will
rachel wallace get her job back
uh i will have to check and see in the
internal hr process i'm happy to do that
and then since you've made it clear that
he was he resigned he was not fired
um how does this comport with president
biden's pledge
to fire you quote on the spot if he
found out about any kind of mistreatment
of the voice so what we did
in early in the administration after he
made those comments which i think that
were the first or second day in office
was
our team our hr team our legal team
others work to put in place a safe and
respectful workplace policy and that
policy which is about a six-page
document i think we've made it available
to all of you and we're happy to
re-share it if useful that was the
process through which uh there was an
investigation
into these
these allegations uh there was a
conclusion of that investigation at the
conclusion of that
eric lander dr eric lander met with
senior members of our officials who made
clear what steps needed to be taken and
that he would be required to be
compliant with those so that was
actually an implementation of the
president's commitment and in an effort
to create a process for a large
administration to maintain a healthy
work environment and create a channel to
address issues as they come up
on the spot after an investigation well
i think in any workplace and one where
like the white house you need to have a
process and a process through which
employees can uh present any concerns
they have uh any allegations they have
and that there's a process that does
those can be seen through and that's
exactly what happened in this case
ukraine if you could explain to
ordinary americans who find the
domestic politics of other countries
very mystifying
why couldn't chancellor schultz say
the words nordstrom
pipeline he was asked numerous times not
just in the press conference yesterday
but also later in interviews
why why can't he spit out the words that
president biden said
well here's what i can speak for which
is the u.s government of course and
president biden
and our commitment uh and agreement uh
that
if russia invades nordstrom 2 will not
move forward it is still not operational
at this point in time
i'm just asking if you can give us any
insights into why
germany can't say that
i i you are a very industrious reporter
amara and i'm sure you can pose that
question to the germans as well but i
can only speak for our government and i
can you heard the president say and
reiterate many times yesterday uh how uh
you know strong our relationship and our
alliance is how germany is one of the
most important alliances allies we have
in the world how we have full confidence
and faith and their commitment uh to
implementing uh a strong uh outcome or
strong consequences should russia invade
glenn thanks jim um if i heard you
correctly earlier you were saying that
president biden was not involved in
directly seeking dr lander's resignation
but can you clarify if he accepted the
resignation because of the investigation
or because of the public outcry around
it
well i would say if you go back to the
letter that dr lander um submitted this
is very small type i don't know if this
means i'm getting older but um
you know what he conveyed in that letter
was that he did not feel that it was
possible to continue effectively in his
role he conveyed that
and he felt and he also conveyed that he
felt the office the work of his office
was too important uh and the president
that was was that the the result of the
public response or the response of his
team you'd have to ask dr lander that
question but the president accepted uh
the resignation letter he submitted last
night it sounds like the investigation
was completed in december so
actually it was it was completed the
full process was completed at the very
end of january
and so why was it why did it not occur
that there was any reprecautions until
after it became public well there was an
entire process that was was underway
including a meeting with dr lander
conveying exactly what steps he would
take he would be required to take that
he would be expected to be compliant
with those requirements and that his
actions were absolutely unacceptable and
would not be tolerated in this white
house and we wanted to prevent them from
happening again so that process had
under had been undergone it's standard
um and and of course these things are
reported sometimes as they were but to
keep hr processes um private in part
because you're protecting the range of
officials who came forward um and uh and
that is that is the standard process
sometimes officials speak publicly as
they did in this case and then that's
their prerogative
can you say when the president learned
of the internal investigation and if he
was briefed on it before this became a
more public subject yesterday
he was made aware uh in advance of the
uh after the conclusion of the
investigation uh but beyond that i don't
have any updates on the timeline just
one more um a few weeks ago the
president had talked about in his press
conference about the desire to get out
of washington yes uh so he's still
trying he's trying to get on that plane
that's my question i guess he's had a
trip to pittsburgh he's had a trip to
new york as you alluded earlier he's
going to virginia
um
is this the robust kind of schedule that
he's looking for or is there something
that's keeping him in washington can you
talk a little bit well i think there are
a couple things that that obviously
every president juggles and including
this president is juggling right now um
if he could spend every day on the road
he probably would do that um and you
know any when you're traveling as
president you know the world comes with
you a bit but uh there's certainly an
open supreme court um uh spot that he
needs to fill he takes very seriously
wants to approach that uh very thorough
from a with a thorough approach uh of
course he's getting regular updates on
russia ukraine from his russia and
ukraine and the uh build-up of troops on
the border um so there are a number of
of of course uh important priorities
that at times can keep a president here
and or maybe are keeping the president
here however um i think we'll we'll be
getting out there more he'll be getting
out there more in the country otherwise
maybe he'll fire one of us i don't know
but um he's he's eager to do that he
wants to be out in the country and i
think as we get to
the period of time post-state of the
union i think you'll see more of that go
ahead thanks jen just a quick follow-up
on kelly has the president spoken with
congressman clyburn about his advocacy
that has been very prominent for judge j
michelle child for the supreme court i
don't have any updates on specific
members he's engaged with beyond the
ones i've i've we've read out or you've
seen publicly uh though i would say
members of our supreme court team uh
you're very familiar with have been
engaged with a range of members
including mr clydman and back on ukraine
what was the president's response to
this u.s assessment that a russian
invasion of ukraine could kill 25 to 50
000 civilians and cause a humanitarian
crisis that would end up with 5 million
refugees
well first let me say we're not going to
get into intelligence assessments from
here obviously um but we certainly uh
prepare for a range of contingencies um
and work and and engage with our
european partners and counterparts to
prepare for them and that relates to the
potential for refugees it relates to the
potential for natural gas or oil
shortages and those are part of the
discussions the president is a part of
our secretary of state is a part of and
that is why we are doing so much
engagement at this point on nordstrom 2
the president was pretty confident
yesterday that it would not go forward
if russia invaded ukraine even though
the german chancellor would not say that
so i guess logistically speaking how
would the president ensure that that
would not happen
i'm just not going to get into more
specifics from here but i can assure you
that that is a commitment um and and one
we will deliver on that sanctions on
anyone or any company that does business
with the pipeline what does that look
like i understand why you're asking i
just don't have more details i can
outline from here at this point in
hindsight does he regret waving
sanctions on the company by nordstrom 2
as the administration did last year well
nordstrom 2 is not operational
at this point in time
and it remains a point of leverage
well it's not the the german regulators
have not approved it so it's not
operational it hasn't been uh so i don't
think we're looking in the rearview
mirror i think we're looking at as a
point of leverage with the russians i
guess the question is that putin has
been quite aggressive in his stance with
ukraine he's amassed over 100 000 troops
on their border he clearly is seeking to
use leverage over them so why let the
pipeline go forward at all regardless of
an invasion given the tactics that he's
been using well again i would say that
we there's a disagreement i'm not sure
this is what you're asking but between
us and some in congress who suggest that
uh that sanctioning
north stream to now would be effective
we don't agree we believe that it is a
point of leverage and that uh making
clear it will not proceed if russia
invades is a point of leverage and
that's why we're proceeding on the path
we are
we don't think that approach would work
go ahead uh there's been some reporting
that the president biden
has
kind of refused to mention tesla when
he's talking about electric vehicles has
kind of been something around that today
you mentioned tesla when he was talking
about electric vehicles anything
noteworthy there any change in
in how he approaches this
i would just note i think we all know
that tesla is a major producer of
electric vehicles i think that's fair to
say factually um and certainly uh the
electric vehicle industry is one that uh
we feel is a huge opportunity for the
united states to move towards our clean
energy goals and objectives and a range
of uh auto
automobile makers are part of that
effort
the house version of the china
competition bill includes a measure that
would require a broad screening process
of outbound international investments
into china
not in this not in the senate one does
that does the white house support that
particular measure i know uh national
security adviser sullivan has discussed
that in general yeah so right now as as
you know they're in conference or
they're discussing um and we are looking
at the impact of outbound u.s investment
flows that could circumvent the spirit
of export controls or otherwise enhance
the technological capacity of our
competitors which is something i think
our national security advisor has
touched on uh and ways that would harm
our national security we would certainly
be concerned by
we're in touch with congress about the
proposal and also our efforts broadly in
this regard uh but again we're going to
keep working that through congress and
that's with with leaders there and
that's what they were the focus is at
this point last question uh does the
climate of high oil and gas prices
influence
how the white house administration
approaches sanctions on iran and
venezuela with an eye getting more
supplies into the market
well let me uh let me just outline for
you and i know i don't know if edward's
here oh there you are he asked me this
question yesterday and i just wanted
more details so i'm just i'm just coming
back to it a little bit um you know the
president's focused on doing everything
we can to uh to address the squeeze that
we know gas prices can have on families
um as he has said supply of oil around
the world should be keeping up with the
demand as we're exiting the pandemic so
there's a couple of areas that we are
focused on and you're familiar with them
but let me just outline them from here
we're engaging one internationally both
with oil producing and oil consuming
countries these discussions are
happening right now they're ongoing with
oil producing countries uh we're talking
about product proposed production
increases with oil consuming countries
we're talking about releases from
strategic reserves of course we're not
going to outline every conversation but
that's largely how we're approaching it
two the president's going to continue to
use every tool at his disposal to reduce
prices we've already announced a
historic release from the strategic
petroleum reserve last fall 40 of 50
million barrels 40 million barrels of
those barrels are con contracted for
delivery including a num 13 million that
we just released in january so as you
this is not it wasn't that 50 million
released at once they're continuing to
be released we saw a drop in prices
which fell more than 10 cents a gallon
in the course of the holiday season
after some of that initial
release and all options remain on the
table third we're focused on protecting
consumers from abuse we know markets
have been volatile often firms
exploit market volatility to extract
excess profits from consumers we're
looking at every legal and regulatory
authority we have available to ensure
consumers are protected that means
responding to any sign of manipulation
in the oil commodities markets or
gauging at the pump uh so we are looking
at it we are approaching it through all
of those forums and the president's
overarching view on prices of course is
that he wants to address the squeeze on
consumers is that uh nobody uh
now that we that even with uh barrels
even with those barrels release prices
are rising that's because supply is not
keeping up with the demand we know that
is the issue the core issue nobody
should hold back supply at the expense
of the american consumer particularly as
the recovery from the pandemic continues
and oil producers around the world have
the capacity to produce at levels that
match demand and reduce the high prices
that is what we're going to continue to
convey one real quick point of
clarification
you announced the the um the cooperative
releases already and in that statement
you suggested maybe there's
conversations are ongoing should we
assume that there's there may be future
cooperative releases then all options
remain on the table but i don't have
anything to preview at this point in
time good yeah i've been following up on
the trucker question from earlier uh
inspired by the the so-called green
convoy in canada
canada a group of us truckers say
they're planning a similar protest in
washington d.c
possibly for march first to oppose
coveted vaccine mandates that dates
obviously that would coincide with
president biden's state of the union
address as you know the trucker convoy
in ottawa has been very disruptive and
paralyzed parts of the city's downtown
is the administration making
preparations to be ready for an upcoming
freedom convoy plan for dc and does
white house have any concerns about this
similar a similar protest happening here
in the nation's capital uh and do you
mean by preparations like security
preparations or do you mean
or is it on your radar i i'd have to
check with our team on security
preparations i think what i would just
reiterate here is that uh we know that
uh requirements work uh we have not seen
a disruption as it relates to
requirements to the industry where we
have seen disruptions has been related
to
these convoys and protests now everybody
can peacefully protest we fully support
that but it's important to note where
the disruption is occurring on a
different topic forgive me if i missed
this earlier does the white house plan
to fill dr landrieu's position how
quickly would you want to nominate
somebody
oh we do i don't have an update on the
timing uh but certainly the president is
confident in the
expertise of the ostp team and their
ability to move forward on uh key
components of the agenda they're
responsible for topic the white house
has recently held kind of local ecd
announcements here with the intel uh
project two weeks ago in ohio today with
uh the electric vehicle station facility
in london tennessee and so i'm trying to
i'm curious what is the federal
government's role then in these sorts of
announcements versus uh the governors of
these two states um in terms of getting
these uh uh projects
so just to understand your question what
are we in terms of how do we get them
the money yeah these are traditionally
the kind of projects you might expect
the governor to announce uh instead
we're seeing them here in the white
house what kind of role uh is the biden
administration have i mean are you
working in tandem with these governors
or is it typically yes exactly and if
the governor can attend we typically
invite them and sometimes they've taken
place in states and
you know i think it's important
president believes it's important to
lift up the ingenuity of american
businesses and companies and especially
companies that are creating jobs
here in the united states and putting
people back to work
katie thanks jen um
as most people in this room have asked
about the president said yesterday that
he would shut down nordstrom 2 if there
was a military invasion he kind of
defined it traditionally as tanks on the
ground so if putin
attacks but doesn't send massive forces
over the border perhaps through cyber
attacks or through paramilitary forces
does the president feel the western
alliance could still present a united
front
given his conversation with the
chancellor yesterday sure we have a
range of contingency i certainly
understand your question but i don't
have anything more to detail here
obviously we don't think nordstrom 2 is
a good deal or a good project we've been
very clear about that and i think right
now what we're focused on is what we
think the right
diplomatic tactic is as it relates to
deterrence which is part of our approach
and that includes making clear that
nordstrom 2 will not proceed given of
course president putin and the russians
want it to proceed but we have a range
of contingencies should putin invade
should he take other additional steps
and we're going to continue to uh work
to be locked up with our partners
clarify so if it's a cyber attack or
paramilitary or anything besides tanks
would he pull well i know it's not
operational but would he stop nordstrom
from going forward
again i don't have anything more to
update you on uh we have a range of
contingencies uh depending on if any
steps that president putin takes and
then he still keep the science advisor
post would that still be cabinet level i
know that was adverse with that okay
go ahead karen
um the president said yesterday he
believes president putin still has a
diplomatic off-ramp that de-escalation
is still possible last month at the
press conference less than three weeks
ago the president said about putin my
guess is he will move in he has to do
something does he no longer believe that
president putin has to do something and
if that's the case what has changed in
those couple of weeks well i mean he
either has to de-escalate or invade
obviously our preference is that he
de-escalates um so
i'm not sure i think that's what the
president likely meant in the time
we still we didn't at the time nor do we
now have an assessment of him making a
decision
are and we can't control what russia
will do next what we can do is we can
prepare and we can prepare for a range
of contingencies and we can stay
coordinated with our partners and allies
and that's what our focus has been you
mentioned at the top of the thursday
event in virginia's prescription drugs
can you tell us more about that where
he's going why virginia and will we have
an announcement on prescription drugs um
i expect we'll have more uh tomorrow as
we get a little bit closer but he's
going outside of richmond to
congresswoman abigail spanberger's
district i think she's she will be at
the event as well as i understand it and
certainly talking about the need to
to reduce the cost of prescription drugs
something that is
bearing a lot of weight on seniors on
families across the country is something
that is still a initiative of a priority
that we we still have more work to get
done
go ahead
thanks jen um on that thursday trip has
the president invited the republican
governor of virginia to join him let me
check and see what if we have more
details on the specifics it's still all
final getting finalized and i expect
we'll have more as we get closer
tomorrow but i'll see if we have any
more we can get you up to everything so
would he plan to talk to him about their
sort of differences and opinion on
masking in schools let me just see who's
been invited to the event and who's
planning to attend and and we'll get you
more details from there
good thank you
another one on ukraine yesterday after
meeting putin president michael said
that one of the options for ukraine
would be to get a status like the one
finland had during the cold war status
of um street neutrality
is that also an option the president
will consider well i saw that president
macron said this morning that was not a
formulation he used and that ending
nato's open door policy would be a
problem we agree with that
and as we've said previously we're
committed to the right of sovereign
nations to make their own decisions
about their security and maybe
we see there is a very intense
diplomatic budget going on uh
around moscow and does the president
believe that it is really helpful or
maybe that it creates like uncertainties
around the situation and could
ultimately benefit the russians you mean
president putin engaging in diplomatic
conversations a lot of diplomatic
conversations and after every encounter
there is a press conference and there
are new questions about are the allies
are really aligned uh is it maybe
concerned that there is maybe too much
going on
i think what you hear from the allies
time and time again is that we are
aligned uh and we there will be severe
consequences and uh that does not mean
that consequences will be identical from
every country it means we agree that uh
invading ukraine a sovereign country uh
is violates global norms and we have
worked hard through more than 200
engagements to uh it doesn't happen by
accident i guess is my point uh to
ensure that we remain uh coordinated and
uh closely uh closely working together
go ahead thank you jen two topics the
first one uh is gonna be the truckers
and then russia but first the the kenyan
the movement in canada the truckers
so the ottawa mayor has asked for 1800
additional police police officers to
quell what he called the insurrection
you know that it's been a rallying cry
for the far right this movement and
prime minister trudeau yesterday accused
the protesters to of trying to blockade
canada's economy and democracy does the
white house share this perspective on
the movement that's not how we've
described it
do you uh you said yesterday just again
that the cbp was not uh impacted
by the movement at the moment
now with what happened at the bridge it
has had an impact
isn't that considering that now trade is
concerned uh shouldn't the white house
give more if put more emphasis on what's
going on on the other side of the board
i don't think we've ever de-emphasized i
just think i was trying to convey that
uh well there was um
kind of a view
by some that it was related to vaccine
requirements it wasn't it was related to
congestion created by the protests which
i think is for important for people to
understand in terms of what's being done
of course we're closely engaged
department of homeland security would be
the right entity to talk to you
in russia
the russian president yesterday with uh
emmanuel macron
commented and i quote they're trying
they being the west the u.s the nato
trying to calm us down with assurances
that nato is a peaceful and defensive
organization but then he cited iraq
libya belgrade as counter examples what
do you say to that
nato has always been a defensive
alliance it is russia that is let me
finish my answer it is russia that is
building up tens of thousands of troops
at the troops at the border not nato we
are working to plus up support for our
partners they have the ability to
de-escalate we certainly hope they do
that go ahead
this afternoon the white house issued a
statement criticizing florida
legislation that would restrict
classroom discussion of sexual
orientation or gender identity it's
relatively rare for the white house to
weigh in on state level legislation so
you can speak about the decision to
weigh in on this particular bill and why
this issue rose the level that the white
house wanted to put something up there
well for those of you who weren't
following this maybe all of you were but
let me first say that every parent as
one myself too hopes that our leaders
will ensure their children's safety
protection and freedom and today
conservative politicians in florida
rejected those basic values by advancing
legislation that is designed to target
and attack the kids who need the support
support the most
kids from
the lgbtqi plus community who are
already vulnerable to bullying and we've
seen that in study after study and
violence just for being themselves and
just for being who they are
make no mistake this is not an isolated
action in florida across the country
we're seeing republican leaders taking
action to regulate what students can or
cannot read what they can or cannot
learn and most troubling who they can or
cannot be this is who these kids are and
these these legislators are trying to
make it harder for them to be who they
are so we felt it was important to speak
out against uh this action uh and uh
speak really um uh and and felt it was
important to do that today go ahead
what's the white house reaction to the
supreme court uh late yesterday
restoring an alabama voting map that a
lower court ruled was discriminatory
yeah um this is a very important story
um so i would say that um
um
need to make sure as you've heard the
president say that our sacred voting
rights are fully protected we should be
moving forward not backward that is
always the view of the president the
vice president in this white house that
means ensuring fair election maps that
protect the rights of black voters to
have an equitable and meaningful
opportunity to elect candidates of their
choice as the voting rack right attack
and supreme court precedent have
guaranteed for decades it is deeply
disturbing to us that the supreme court
gave alabama a free pass to use a map
that in 2022 that three federal judges
found to discriminate against black
voters this is exactly what the voting
rights act is in place to prevent and
what in one of the reasons it's so
important to pass a reauthorization into
law uh without and they did this without
the supreme court finding any reason to
doubt uh that conclusion that is
concerning to us uh and certainly uh
protecting people's rights not taking
steps backward is our objective the
administration as you know through the
justice department uh took legal action
against texas they challenged those maps
perceived as being discriminatory given
that voting rights legislation here in
washington has basically been put on
pause for a number of reasons is the
white house considered any sort of
unilateral or preemptive actions
against states that might try to take
similar steps as texas and alabama again
i understand the question i would point
to the department of justice is as you
know but for others we're not a party to
this lawsuit but i would point you to
the department of justice go ahead hi
thanks um a couple on dr lander uh i
want to be precise first i guess on his
resignation because he said
it became clear to him yesterday
what did the president or anybody else
in the white house encourage him to
resign or was this 100 totally voluntary
this is a decision made by dr lander
and then what does it say to the staff i
guess in the administration
that the president appeared happy to
keep him in his role
until essentially this became public and
became untenable at least in dr lender's
mind
i wouldn't say that's an accurate
depiction of how the president feels or
we feel and so i appreciate the
opportunity to restate that
dr lander's behavior was not acceptable
at all
and the president did not view it as
acceptable either
there was a full process that
was undergone that was an implementation
of the policies put in place last spring
the safe and respectful workplace policy
that included a thorough investigation
it included a meeting of dr lander with
individual senior officials from the
white house team and it included
specific steps he had to take to prevent
this from happening ever again
and i think what people should be
assured of in the white house is that
the president's committed to maintaining
a healthy work environment to creating a
channel also to address any issues that
come up and that channel was created
through this policy last may and lastly
are there any other senior white house
staff or cabinet members who have been
subject to investigations like this and
can the white house commit to making
that public kind of future given that it
was a public scrutiny here that ended up
in the resignation well again i
certainly understand the question and we
want to create an environment here
that's safe and people feel comfortable
and they also know the channel where
they can express concerns as they have
them but this is an hr process and an
internal process because of that and we
typically keep those processes private
to respect the individuals the privacy
of the individuals who come forward if
individuals come forward
and that's how we would proceed moving
forward you can't say yes or no whether
there are other investigations similar
to that again those are private
processes and hr processes and if
individuals choose to speak publicly
that of course is their prerogative but
as is true of any uh hr process and any
company we would certainly keep that
process private as a policy
re-evaluation of the workplace policies
and goals we are given
this given everything that's happened
this year is there any feeling of
needing to go back and revisit but those
are effective and
adequate well i think again our
objective is to prevent this behavior
unacceptable behavior from ever
happening again and the safe and
respectful workplace policy which was
implemented in this case provides a
channel for
any individual to come forward if they
have concerns where the concerns can be
addressed through a thorough process and
hopefully people
know that and it is part of an effort to
maintain a healthy work environment
go ahead
hey thanks jim um immigration reform
seems like a non-starter in the current
congress but today freshman uh
republican
congresswoman presented an immigration
reform bill that would legalize millions
of undocumented and she's calling it a
starting point she's got republican
backing
will the president agree to invite her
to the white house listen to her ideas
and incorporate them somehow well the
president proposed an immigration bill
on his first day in office and certainly
he's eager to work with anybody who
wants to put in place uh com immigration
reform policies that would
create a safer system a more effective
system a more humane system at the
border i'm not familiar with all the
specific details but certainly we engage
with a range of members about their
policies let me just do one last one
here go ahead i wanted to ask for an
update on how many cobia 19 rapid tests
you've received from the president's
pledge to provide free tests have been
sent out
received to you and then sent out to
americans sure i know there's a covid
briefing i think tomorrow or thursday uh
let me check with them and see i don't
have the numbers in front of me but i
can see if they're in a position to
provide an update on that
thanks everyone
okay everyone i'm sorry i think we gotta
wrap up but but more tomorrow let's do
this again
i i'm often answering questions on
africa i'm happy to do some more
tomorrow i'll look forward to talking
all to all of you tomorrow thanks
everyone thank you
you